So, if you recall last class, we
discussed uh finitely repeated games.
Today, we're going to discuss infinitely
repeated games, and we're going to see
that the results are actually uh quite
different.
So, what's the motivation for studying
infinitely repeated games? We can, of
course, debate about whether, you know,
the future's really infinite, whether
it's finite. We can have these
philosophical debates, but I think uh
what we're hoping to capture in these
models is simply the idea that there's
not a natural last period.
So, there's
no
natural
last period.
So, when firms are setting prices,
there's never really a time where they
think there's no opportunity to set
price in the future.
When governments are negotiating,
there's no natural point where they
think the world ends and we're not going
to have further negotiation.
And what we saw is that when we modeled
finitely repeated games, a lot of the
conclusions were driven by these last
period effects, by the fact that in a
finitely repeated game, there's some
period of the game that everyone knows
is the last period of the game, and the
game cannot continue beyond that. We
want to shut that down today and study
games where there's no uh natural last
period. There's going to be some some
key differences between the finite and
the infinite case.
And
what we saw in the finite case is in a
lot of games, like in the prisoner's
dilemma, there was no scope for
cooperation or for punishment and
rewards. So, maybe I'll say
limited
scope
for rewards and punishments.
And this uh came from this last period
effect. We often argued if we know
what's going to happen in the last
period, then we can figure out what's
going to happen in the period before,
and we can keep working backwards using
this kind of backward induction
reasoning.
And it's all driven by the fact that uh
in the last period, there's certainly no
scope for rewards and punishments, and
then that sort of extended earlier in
time.
In the infinite case, we're going to see
um there's actually a huge range of
possibilities. So,
um
maybe we'll say many things can happen.
We'll actually formalize this next
class, but particularly if players are
very patient.
We're going to see that if the players
are patient enough, the future looms
very large, and there's a huge richness
of of possibilities uh for equilibria in
these games.
So, today, the plan is to We're not
going to quite get to this anything can
happen result uh until next class, but
today we're going to set up the
framework of infinitely repeated games,
and then we're going to discuss how we
can achieve cooperation in the
prisoner's dilemma. So, we're going to
focus on the prisoner's dilemma, and
we're going to observe a crucial
difference. In the prisoner's dilemma,
the unique subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium was defection every period.
We're going to see in the infinitely
repeated version, there's scope for a
lot of cooperation.
So, let's set up the
general framework.
So, just as in the finitely repeated
version of the game, we have to have
some stage game that we're going to
repeat. So, as before, we have a stage
game.
And
maybe we'll call this G. Remember, we
had our stage game G, and this was just
a simple strategic form game, but
remember we defined or labeled
strategies in the stage game as actions
rather than strategies, so that we don't
get confused. So, this was uh we had UI
from
A to R
for I equals 1 through N.
So, we have N players.
The players' payoffs depend on action
profiles. So, remember A is A1
cross up to AN. It's the set of action
profiles the players can play in the
stage game, and then we specified the
utilities that the players get as a
function of that.
Now, the difference here is timing.
Whereas before, we said that time was 0
1 2 up to some fixed finite horizon, now
the horizon's infinite. So, now we have
periods
T equals 0 1 2 dot dot dot.
There's no point at which the game
necessarily ends.
And otherwise, everything's the same.
So, in particular, we still have perfect
monitoring of past actions.
Now, the first thing we have to figure
out in a game like this is how we're
going to compute payoffs, because in the
finitely repeated version of the game,
we just could add up the payoffs and
then take the average, right?
But here,
things go on forever. So, it's not clear
how we're going to be able to add up all
the payoffs, and we're going to return
to an idea that we had before, which is
we're going to have discounting.
Uh
So, we're going to use discounted
payoffs.
So, let's see what we mean by that.
Well, what's actually going to happen
What's an outcome of the game, right? In
the finite version, an outcome of the
game was an a profile of actions in the
first in the zeroth period, a profile of
actions in the first period, all the way
up to the last period.
But now, an outcome of the game is an
infinite path of actions. So, we might
say uh
we want to be interested in something
called an action path,
which is something like A0 A1
A2 dot dot dot.
So, this is like an infinite vector.
And this is going to say,
well,
what did everyone do in period zero?
Notice there are no subscripts here. If
I had a subscript I here, that would
mean what player I did in period zero.
But with no subscript, this is what
everyone does in period zero. It's a
profile of actions.
So, just to make sure we're on the same
page, each of these lives in A.
So, an action path says, what did
everyone do in period zero? What did
everyone do in period one? What did
everyone do in period two? And so on.
And what we want to understand is
what payoff the players get from an
action path like this.
You could think of the action path kind
of as playing the role of the terminal
nodes in a finite horizon game.
Remember, we wrote out the extensive
form game, and we had this tree, and we
looked at the terminal nodes.
Here, the game goes on forever, so it's
a bit trickier to think about what a
terminal node is, but this is kind of
the analog of a terminal node in the
infinite horizon game.
And now, we need to understand what
payoff this gives.
So, the payoff from this
is going to be Maybe we'll write UI
of A0 A1 dot dot dot.
We need to say what this is.
And
again, we can't just add it all
together, because it's going to go on
forever. So, we're going to look at the
discounted sum of the payoffs.
So, player I will get UI of A0 in period
zero, because this is the action profile
that's played in period zero, and this
is the stage game utility that player I
gets. So, you can think of this as
player I's flow payoff in period zero.
Then we want to add to that the flow
payoff in period one, but now we have to
discount that.
So, we're going to get delta
times UI
of A1.
So, this is the flow payoff player I
gets from the action profile played in
period one, multiplied by delta, that's
our discount factor, which we've looked
at before, to represent the fact that
payoffs tomorrow matter less than
payoffs today.
And then we keep doing this, right? Then
we'll get delta squared U of
A2,
and we'll continue continue on
like this.
And if you want to write this a bit more
mathematically, we can use summation
notation, so it's the sum.
We're summing over all the periods, and
our index is starting at time zero. So,
we're going to have a sum from T equals
zero to infinity.
And then, what is the discounted flow
payoff in period T? It's delta to the T
times UI of AT.
We're notice when T equals zero, this
just reduces to one. Delta to the zero
is equal to one, and we just get this
first payoff here.
So,
I think this raises a few questions
about the discount factor delta.
The discount factor delta is going to be
a number between zero and one. The idea
is that the future matters less than the
present.
If delta equaled one,
then we wouldn't be able to compute the
summation, because we'd be summing
infinitely many things, and that might
not converge.
Um
how do we interpret this discount factor
delta? I don't know. How do you think of
this?
Um how can we think of this discount
factor?
Why might you value future payoffs less
than payoffs today? Do you feel that you
have a discount factor? If I said I'll
give you $10 today or $10 in 10 years,
which would you prefer? Yeah. Well,
about today due to inflation?
So, say it again. It's due to inflation.
Inflation, right? Um exactly. So, one
one interpretation discount factor,
which is especially relevant if we have
monetary rewards, is inflation and
interest rates, right? So, you could
take that money today and you could
invest it in, say, treasury bills and
you could get a guaranteed return to the
future. So, one interpretation is
sometimes the interest rate,
which is tied tied to inflation.
Um
And under this interpretation, we might
say that delta is equal to 1 over 1 + R.
So, if we have an interest rate R and
we're thinking about monetary payoffs,
then the value of $1 today
is uh the value of $1 tomorrow
has the same value as 1 over 1 + R
dollars today. Why is that? Well, if you
give me 1 over 1 + R dollars today,
and I invest that in a checking account,
and I get a return at rate R, then I'll
multiply this by 1 + R and I'll get my
dollar back tomorrow.
Um of course,
sometimes these utilities are not
monetary payoffs. So, if this is just
how much I enjoy,
you know, a certain item, we can't
literally, you know, I can't take my
utility to the bank and get an interest
rate.
Um so, sometimes we have other
interpretations. Any other reasons why
if I said, "What if I told you I'm going
to give you a really big reward
in a billion years?" Uh yeah.
We'd be dead by then. Right. So, it
could be, you know, people die or maybe
another way of saying it is, you know,
things could end. The game could end.
There could be some reason why you leave
the game, you know, things could happen.
So, one other interpretation of this
discount factor is that there could be
some fixed probability at which the game
ends each period. So, if we wanted to
formalize that, we could say, "What if
the game ends
with probability
1 minus delta each period?"
Well, then we can say, "What's the
probability that we actually get to
tomorrow?"
Well, there's probability 1 minus delta
that the game ends today.
So, the probability that we actually get
to tomorrow is going to be delta, right?
But then, what's the probability that we
get to the day after that? Well, again,
there's only probability delta that the
game continues. So, we could one
interpretation of delta to the T is
saying, "In order for us to get to
period T, we have to transition from
period zero to period one, which has
probability delta. We have to transition
from period one to period two, which has
probability delta, and so on."
And delta to the T is simply
representing the probability that we're
still around or that we survive up until
period T.
Uh
And crucially, if the game ends with
probability 1 minus delta, then it
continues with probability delta. So,
that's a a key
observation. But even if you were
certain the game would continue,
I think people are just impatient. And
this is something that's been documented
in the lab all the time. If I say I'll
give you an ice cream cone today or
tomorrow,
uh you know, we don't have to worry
about inflation cuz I'm giving you an
ice cream cone. I'm not giving you money
to pay for the ice cream cone.
Um
you're pretty likely to be around
tomorrow, but I think a lot of people
would just say I'd rather have ice cream
cone today than tomorrow. This is just
sort of a behavioral fundamental uh
preference. So, we might just say, uh
maybe I'll call this fundamental
impatience.
People are just impatient. This is this
is the way
uh
the way people are.
In reality, you can think of this
discount factor delta as maybe
reflecting some combination of these
forces. Depending on the application, it
may be really about interest rates, it
may be about the game ending, it may be
some combination. Maybe you're worried
that the game will end before tomorrow,
and you're also just fundamentally
impatient. We're not really going to
take a stance in the in the mathematical
conclusions won't really depend on the
interpretation, but we're just going to
have some fixed discount factor delta
that's reflecting
um any any reason for it to discount.
All right. And because of this discount
factor delta, sometimes this game,
remember before we referred to a game,
so just a reminder, remember when we did
finite repetition,
we talked about G of T.
So, we said in the finitely repeated
game, we denoted it by G of T, where we
said this means game G is played up to
horizon capital T.
In the infinite case,
we might talk about G of infinity or
more commonly G of delta.
Because just telling me G of infinity
doesn't give me enough information. That
tells me the game is repeated with an
infinite horizon, but if I don't know
the discount factor, I I'm not I haven't
really fully specified the game. So,
more commonly we'll write G of delta to
indicate the infinitely repeated game uh
with discount factor delta. I mean, more
generally we could have G of
T, delta, but uh normally in the finite
case, we don't do discounting.
So, that's something to keep in mind.
All right.
So, now let's think about what a
strategy is.
So, as before, we just define a strategy
to be a mapping
from histories to actions. So, what do
you What are the contingencies you face
in the game? You're player in the game.
In every period, you can see what
happened before,
and based upon what's happened so far,
you choose an action.
So, a strategy for player I
is going to need to say, "Let's look at
all the periods,
period zero all the way down to period
T.
Go down to period one as well.
Well, if it's period zero,
nothing has happened so far. There's
just a null history. So, we're just
going to specify a single action. We
need to say, "What is S I
of the empty set?"
So, this is going to say, "My strategy
needs to tell me what I'm going to do in
period zero. I know I'm in period zero.
Nothing has happened so far, and I just
need to choose an action."
Then in period one,
I don't just specify one action. I need
to specify a lot of actions because I
need to say what I'm going to do in
period one as a function of or
contingent on how we all played in
period zero.
And that's what H1 represents, right?
So, H1 is going to say, "In period one,
what history of play
What is the history of play? So, for all
Well, where does H1 live? Let's call it
H1. This is the set of histories at
period one. But can we be more precise?
What What is this set going to be? If
it's period one and I observed what
happened last period, what is H1 going
to be?"
What's a history in period one?
Yeah, in the front. What happened in
period zero. Right. And what What's our
notation for that? Do we have
So, what How can we describe what
happened in period zero? What do we need
to say? Or just in words, what What do
we need to specify from period zero?
What each player did in period zero.
What each player did. So, we have to
specify what player one did, what player
two did, all the way to player N. That
means we need to specify a profile of
actions from period zero, and we have
notation for that. That's just A, right?
So, remember our set A
contains profiles of actions that
specify what every player does in the
stage game.
Okay? And then if we go down to period
T,
now things get really complicated
because in period T, we have to specify
what player I does as a function of
every possible history of play. Now, the
history is a lot more complicated. So,
we have for all histories HT
in HT
equal So, now what is HT? Well, it's
period T,
so I know how people played in period
zero.
I know how they played in period one,
and I know how they played all the way
up to period T minus one.
So, that means altogether, I know T
action profiles. So, this is going to be
A
T.
So, let's just make sure we understand.
So, as an example,
HT would look something like this. It's
going to say, "This is how people played
in period zero.
This is how people played in period one.
And this is how people played in T minus
one."
So, a time T history
looks something like this
because we specify action profiles from
zero all the way up to T minus one. We
have to specify T action profiles
altogether, and that's why we have A to
the T here. So, the set A to the T
is just the set of all
uh vectors that look like this. Yes? And
so,
like little A zero, that includes an
action for every I. Exactly right. So,
let's So, this is kind of tricky because
this is like a nested vector, right?
What is A zero?
This is A zero one
A N
A zero N.
Right? So, you could if you wanted, you
could think of this kind of like a
matrix,
right? We have to specify what hap- what
every player did in every uh period. So,
we have to specify number for each
player and for each time.
Uh and we're going to be really
consistent about this. The superscripts
are always going to be about time,
and the subscripts are always going to
be about the players.
So, we have subscript I tells me which
player I am I talking about, and that I
can vary from one to N cuz those are the
players.
A superscript T
can vary from zero to infinity cuz that
tells me what period I'm in.
Now,
I like this notation
Uh to it's consistent but I guess one
downside of this notation is it can be
unclear whether
a number like this is a superscript
just a label or whether it actually
means
multiplying things together. So let me
just kind of give you a warning about
this, right? When I write
and if you're confused at any point let
me know, when I write delta to the T
delta is a number.
So here delta to the T is the number
delta multiplied by itself T times. So
this is multiplication.
When I write A0 or A1 I can't multiply A
by itself cuz A is A is not a number.
This is just a symbol it's just
notation.
And I guess I'm actually being
uh
a little I guess unclear here a little
naughty because this is just a symbol
this is just a symbol but this actually
is the product of sets. So
um maybe I'll write
to avoid that confusion let me write
this as A
times itself T times.
But if you're ever unsure about what
notation means let me know because I
think sometimes the biggest barrier in
setting repeated games is just getting
the notation right. But once you get the
notation I think everything should be
clear.
Okay, so formally
what is a strategy? Well, a strategy has
to say what I do at every single
history.
So we could try to think of a strategy
you know, writing out these spaces and
talking about you know, okay, we have
the null history we have some history
here we have some history here and so
on.
The problem is this list is going to go
on forever. So this is going to be
pretty complicated to write down. So
we're just going to denote a strategy as
a function.
What is it?
It's a function SI
from H to AI.
This says at every history H I'm going
to specify what I do.
But I haven't defined what the set H is
so let's just think carefully about what
H is where H
is just going to collect all the
histories together.
I'm just going to take all the histories
and put them together. So I'm going to
collect the period zero history.
Well, that's just the empty set. So I
need to put that in there.
Then the period one histories.
H1 union H2 union dot dot dot.
Erase this here.
So here the union this is just set
theory notation but it doesn't matter.
All all I'm saying is I'm going to
collect together
the zero history, all the histories in
period one, all the histories in period
two, all the histories in period three
and so on and put them all together in a
set. And then my strategy is going to
tell me what action I take as a function
of every possible history that I'm at.
All right, any any questions on this?
Yeah.
So okay, just to make sure I understand
Yeah, absolutely. The last one can you
write a set of different actions you
would do for each possible history at
each stage? Uh yeah, not so
it it will specify a single one, right?
AI says what I specify lives in AI. So
AI is a set. AI is the set of actions I
could take but a single strategy SI a
single function will say at every single
history what action will I do. But at
every single possible history for each
period. At every single possible history
for each period. So if I want to break
it down I could think of SI as just
encoding
a different you know, a different sub
strategy for every history. It has kind
of a period zero part that tells me what
I do in period zero as a function of
well, in period zero there's only one
history so it's kind of easy. In period
one what I do at every period one
history. Then in period two what I do at
every period two history and on and on.
So you can think of it as kind of a list
of functions. Um you know, we're not
really going to deal with this formal
notation too much but I just want us to
kind of know what what the objects are
and what's going on. Yeah, great
question. Uh any other clarifications or
questions?
Okay.
So now we want to apply the one-shot
deviation principle to understand
subgame perfect Nash equilibria of this
game. So now our goal
is to study or analyze
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
of these infinitely repeated games.
Now remember step one if you want to
analyze subgame perfect Nash equilibria
is always understand the subgames. So
what we want to do is understand
what are the
uh all the subgames in this infinitely
repeated game.
And
the key observation is that
each subgame
each history
H starts a subgame.
But now what's tricky is you know, in
the finitely repeated version
what the subgame looked like depended on
how far along in the game we were. If
our subgame started right before the end
of the game we didn't have many periods
left.
But in the infinitely repeated game
whatever period we're in the future
actually looks the same. The future is
still infinite. So let's try to
understand what a subgame starting at
history H looks like.
Um
so just to make it maybe concrete let's
take uh
eight let's take T equals
two just to make things really simple.
So let's look at a history
and consider a history
H2
which is going to specify A0
A1.
So what I'm going to say is let's look
at the subgame where we're in period
two.
We know what's happened so far. We know
the history and what is this history?
It's going to tell us what happened in
period zero and what happened in period
one. And I'm using the bar notation just
to say this is fixed. So you could think
of this as A this is just a symbol. I'm
writing the bar just to um
I think it'll be a little clearer below
what's going on. But this is a fixed
action profile A0 and this is a fixed
action profile A1.
And as before
this tells me what every single player
did in period zero and this tells me
what every single player did in period
one.
Okay.
So now
we can think of our subgame
as we're at A0
we're at A1.
Here we are. This is our history.
And then
play is going to continue. Right? The
subgame is sort of everything from here
on out.
Right?
And just to understand what's going to
happen let's say the way we play is
going to induce some action profile A2
some action profile A3 some action
profile A4 and so on and it's going to
go all the way forward, right?
So let's try to understand what our
payoff is going to be
in this
particular subgame.
So our payoff
is just going to be
let's look at player I.
The payoff for player I is going to be
UI
of A0
plus delta
UI
of A1
plus delta squared
UI of A2 plus delta cubed UI
of A3
and so on.
So technically if you want to compute
our payoffs we have to keep track of all
the actions here.
But a key observation is that this part
isn't really going to matter for this
subgame.
Because once this is the history and
once we're considering how we're going
to play moving forward these actions
have already been chosen.
So these actions just serve as a
constant.
Once I've made it to period two
how I played in period zero and period
one it adds to my payoff but it doesn't
really matter for my decisions today
because whatever I do moving forward
these have already happened.
And these numbers are already here.
And if we focus on this part
we can it's convenient to factor out the
delta
to the two. So let's just factor this
out.
And we're going to get delta squared
times
UI
A2
plus delta UI
A3
plus dot dot dot.
And what we know from von
Neumann-Morgenstern utilities is that if
I take a utility function and I add a
constant to it and I multiply it by a
constant that doesn't really change my
preferences.
So all that really matters is this.
So often and from here on out when we're
looking at a subgame instead of writing
out the payoffs like this which is maybe
formally correct we're just going to
directly jump to this cuz this is what
matters. And we're going to say if
you're in the period three
subgame all that matters is
your payoff today plus delta times your
payoff tomorrow and so on. And we only
need to sort of look at what happens
moving forward we don't have to look
back at the past.
Um so this is going to be uh
This is what matters and this is what
we're going to use as the subgame
payoff.
Okay, so now that we've kind of
set that up, let's now uh try to
actually construct an equilibrium.
So let me come back over here.
So let's consider the prisoner's
dilemma.
So remember we have cooperate, defect,
cooperate, defect.
Uh
2 2, 3 -1, -1 3, 0 0.
So now let's Our goal today and for the
rest of the class is to find
SPNE
of
the infinitely repeated version of the
prisoner's dilemma. So maybe I'll write
PD
of delta.
What I mean here is the stage game is
the prisoner's dilemma.
We're going to repeat this game
infinitely many times
and the discount factor we're going to
use is delta.
Both players use this discount factor.
So we want to try to find subgame
perfect Nash equilibria of this game and
as context let's recall
what did we see about PD of a fixed T?
So the finitely repeated version of the
prisoner's dilemma, we analyzed that on
Tuesday. Does anyone recall what the
subgame perfect Nash equilibria of that
game were?
So remember on Tuesday we had a result
that said, if a stage game has a unique
Nash equilibrium,
then the finitely repeated version of
that game also has a unique subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium. Yep.
>> [snorts]
>> They just defect every period, right?
And they do And more importantly, they
defect whatever's happened in the past.
So the finitely repeated version of the
prisoner's dilemma
had a unique equilibrium, had unique
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
And what was it? It was
SI
S1 of H
equals D
for every history H.
And similarly S2 of H equals D for every
H.
And again, we always have to be really
clear
about the difference between the outcome
of a game and the strategies in the
game.
So the outcome of this subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium was we defect every
period.
But just saying that we defect every
period doesn't specify the strategies.
Cuz the strategies have to say not only
what we do do, but what we would have
done had play been different.
So the strategies are this. We're saying
not only do we actually defect, but we
would have defected had the history been
different.
And in fact here then the subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium is at every
history we always defect.
So now we want to understand how is the
infinitely repeated version of
different?
We studied the PD of T.
So
so how is the infinite horizon
different?
Any thoughts? Do people have intuition?
Do you think
people will be able to cooperate more?
How do you think the infinite horizon
might be different? I don't know. Will
this still be an equilibrium?
Any thoughts?
Um
So it turns out
that in the infinite horizon, we still
have this
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium, but
we're going to have a lot of other
equilibria as well.
So the first point is that
maybe I'll call it
star.
I'll call that strategy profile star. So
star
is still
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
of the infinitely repeated version.
Let's check this. Okay?
So here's Let's check.
We have a strategy profile. We want to
check that it's a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium. How do we do that? Well, we
have to check that in every subgame, it
gives us a Nash equilibrium.
To make that easier, we're going to
apply the one-shot deviation principle.
So by the one-shot deviation principle,
we only need to check one-shot
deviations.
One-shot deviations,
but we do have to check them at every
history.
I want to really emphasize this. So I
think one common mistake that I see is
people say, "Oh, we'll apply the
one-shot deviation principle. We're
looking for the the equilibrium where we
always defect. So let's just look at a
history where we've always defected so
far and then check that no one wants to
deviate."
But that's not enough. You have to
consider every history, even histories
that wouldn't happen under this strategy
profile. So we have to take into account
what happens at histories like
cooperate, cooperate, cooperate, even
though those histories won't actually
happen.
Okay.
So let's
consider a fixed history H.
And let's consider player I.
Maybe player one to make it easier.
So at some history H,
let's consider player one. They're
choosing between two things.
They can either choose
defect or cooperate.
Okay?
So we're at history H.
Defect is what they're supposed to do
because we want to check that always
defecting is a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium. So we want to compare
defecting,
which is what they're supposed to do,
to the one-shot deviation where instead
of defecting today, they cooperate
and then from here on after, they would
return to their equilibrium strategy.
So what does the future look like if the
player follows their equilibrium
strategy? Well, today they get DD.
Why? Well, player one is defecting today
and the other player's strategy is to
always defect.
Then the next period they get DD. The
next period DD.
So DD. Cuz this is just what happens in
equilibrium. So if the player does what
they're supposed to and we follow the
equilibrium path of play, then from
today onward, we're just going to get
defect defect
from here on out.
What if the player one-shot deviates to
C? Now what happens?
What does the future look like? What is
the future path of play going to be?
Any thoughts?
Yeah. You're fine. Um shouldn't they
write in the one-shot deviation?
Uh so I guess what I'm saying is here So
we're at history H in Let me say in
period T.
And I guess maybe my notation was
unclear. This is period T.
Exactly. So I'm I'm including what
happens today, right? So, you know, to
go to this example here, if T equals 2,
I'm starting right here inside the
inside the game. Yeah. Uh
good good clarification. So indeed it'll
be CD today.
Why is it CD today? Well, my opponent is
playing D today because their strategy
says they always play D whatever the
history.
And I'm player one. I'm deviating to C.
We have to be clear, defect and deviate
are not the same. So I'm deviating to
the strategy C.
I play C, my opponent plays D, but now
what happens up here? Now you said DD, I
agree, but but why?
Why is it DD up here? Yeah? Because it's
only a one-shot D. Because it's a
one-shot deviation, right? We know that
the second player is always playing D.
So let's understand kind of the two re-
the reasoning for this. We know the
future has to look like this
for the second player because this is a
unilateral deviation. So if it's a
unilateral deviation by player one,
player two is simply going to follow
their equilibrium strategy and their
strategy is to always defect. So we know
that player two is always defecting.
What's tricky though is I could consider
a more complicated deviation as player
one
where I cooperate today and then I
continue doing weird things in the
future.
But since this is only a one-shot
deviation, once I get here, I'm supposed
to do exactly what my strategy
specifies, which is D. So we get DD, DD,
DD.
And now is this deviation, this one-shot
deviation, profitable? We have to ask,
is this future better than this future
or not?
Well,
these look all the same. So, the only
difference comes down to this period.
But, if I do what I'm supposed to do and
I defect, I get a payoff of
uh
zero.
But, if I cooperate and the other player
defects, I get a payoff of negative one.
And thereafter, the payoffs are the
same.
So, this is better than this and indeed
I've shown that the player does not have
a profitable deviation.
So, we've checked that this is a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
So, this is the equilibrium that looks a
lot like the equilibrium of the finitely
repeated game.
The difference with the infinitely
repeated game, however, is that there
are also other equilibria where we do
cooperate.
So, now the question is
how can we sustain cooperation?
in a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
So, we could get into the math, but
let's just think about it. You played
this game with your friends yesterday on
or on Tuesday.
And some of you were able to sustain
cooperation. How did you do it? What did
you think would happen? So, if you play
this game with your friends
and those of you who did play cooperate
uh each period, why did you do that?
What did you think would happen if you
didn't cooperate?
What was your your strategy that you
were using? What was your plan? Yeah? I
guess my idea is like in this round, if
my friend cooperates but wait, if my
friend
uh
if I cooperate, I defect in the next
round, I should probably start to defect
and then we would go getting two two to
zero zero.
Right. So, so generally the idea is
uh
if
my friend
defects and chooses D and kind of messes
my payoff up, I'm going to punish them
in the future by playing D as well.
Right? Um
that's something called tit-for-tat and
we're going to analyze that a bit later.
We're going to start with something even
simpler, which is called the grim
trigger strategy.
You can imagine very complicated things
where maybe if my opponent defects, I'm
going to punish them for like three
periods and then go back to cooperating.
But, here we're going to think of a very
vindictive player.
And the idea of the grim trigger
strategy is
if anyone ever defects,
I'm going to defect from here on out.
Uh so,
let's write this down.
So, we have
S1 of H. We'll look at player one, it's
the same. Oh, we can do I, it doesn't
matter.
So, we're defining a strategy.
That means we have to define what this
player does at every history.
And we're going to define this
piecewise. We're going to say, well,
there's some histories where no one has
defected so far.
So, we're going to break up the
histories in two. We're going to say if
H
does not contain D,
So, what do I mean by this?
What a history that does not contain D
means at this point in time, if we look
back at the way the game has been
played, no one ever defected.
And that either means we're in period
zero, so maybe no one defected because
there we didn't play at all, we're in
period zero, or it means we're after
period zero, but when we look back,
people cooperated the whole time.
And then we have other histories where
someone has already defected. We're
looking back and some player has
defected.
So, what's the idea here? If it doesn't
contain D and we've cooperated so far,
intuitively, what should we do?
We should cooperate, right? So far
everyone's cooperated, so we're going to
cooperate.
But, if someone has defected in the
past, then we're going to defect as
well.
So, this is the grim trigger strategy.
The trigger
is someone defecting.
That's what triggers us to move from
cooperating to defecting.
It's grim because once someone defects,
we defect forever after.
This is the harshest, grimmest possible
punishment we can impose.
Want to point out one kind of strange
thing about this strategy. When I say
contains D, this means by either player.
So, in particular, let's say in period
zero,
the players play CD.
Then, what is the grim trigger strategy
going to specify
in period one?
Yeah.
DD, right?
Now,
for player one, I think this is very
natural. Let's think of this from the
perspective of player one.
They look back to period zero.
They say, I cooperated,
but my opponent defected. I'm unhappy
with them. I'm going to punish them by
defecting tomorrow.
Or defecting today, sorry. We're in
period one. I'm going to defect today
because yesterday my opponent, player
two, defected. That makes sense, right?
What about player two though? This is a
little weird, right?
What is player two's thought process
here?
Uh yeah, in the front. Maybe you're
anticipating the punishment, so you're
trying to avoid it as much as possible.
Exactly. So, what's weird about player
two
is they're looking back and they're
saying, wait, player one cooperated with
me yesterday. That's great.
I'm the one who defected. I'm the bad
guy.
Yet nevertheless, under this strategy,
player two is defecting today exactly
for the reason you pointed out.
I'm not defecting to punish myself.
I'm defecting because I I see that
because I defected, I anticipate that my
opponent is going to defect today and if
they're going to defect today, why don't
I just defect as well?
So,
it has this weird feature that it might
appear that players are punishing
themselves, their own misbehavior, but
really they're anticipating the other
players' punishment and responding to
that exactly as you said. Great
observation.
Okay, so now we want to check, is this a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium?
Well, the answer is going to depend on
delta. And let's first, I always think
it's good in these questions to try to
intuit which way it's going to go before
you solve the algebra. It's good to
build intuition and it's also helpful on
exams. If you have a sense of what the
solution should look like and then you
make a an algebra mistake, you're able
to catch it, right? So, it's going to
depend on delta. Is your intuition that
this is going to be a a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium when delta is high or
when delta is low?
So, I'm going to tell you for some delta
this will be a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium. For some delta it won't.
It's going to depend on delta. For which
one do you think it'll work? High delta
or low delta?
Yeah.
Just a guess, but the higher the delta
or just a high delta and then it will be
a subgame perfect.
I agree and uh what's your intuition for
that? Yeah?
Because you're getting a higher payoff
really early, which means if you have a
high delta, only the high only that
early payoff will matter.
Uh so, almost. I mean, we have to think
with a high delta, it's always the case
that later payoffs matter less.
But, with a high delta, they just
matter less the amount less they matter
is less. Um so, it's still true that the
the future matters. The present is sort
of the most important period, but it's
almost as important as
uh sorry, the present is always more
important. Today's always more important
than tomorrow, but when delta's close to
one, today is uh tomorrow is almost as
important as today. Is it a better way
of saying it? Um so, I think that's part
of the intuition and the other
intuition, why do you think
high delta is going to make this
Let's think of the incentives of the
players.
Let's suppose the player thinks about
deviating or sorry, thinks about
defecting.
Okay?
What happens if a player defects in this
game under this strategy intuitively?
Yeah?
They
They lose [clears throat] all future
benefits of cooperating. Exactly. But,
what happens to them today? That's
exactly right. And then today, what
happens? They gain the extra payoff.
Exactly. So, if we've cooperated so far
and I'm thinking about what to do, I
face a tradeoff.
If I defect today, I increase my payoff
today,
but I get punished in the future by my
opponent.
So, I'm trading off the benefits of
defecting today against the losses I
experience in the future.
And if I'm patient enough,
those losses in the future loom large
and will discourage me
from defecting. And therefore, will
sustain a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium.
On the other hand, we can think of the
extreme case, if delta is basically
zero, let's take delta to be zero.
If delta is zero, then this is just a
one-shot game.
And we know in the one-shot game, the
unique equilibrium is defect. So, we
know this can't be a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium when delta is zero.
So, intuitively, we expect the higher
delta is, the easier it will be to
sustain this as an equilibrium and let's
check it and and confirm whether that
intuition is correct.
I should make, I guess, one comment. Uh
just a technical comment.
I'm applying the one-shot deviation
principle.
The one-shot deviation principle applies
to multi-stage games that are
continuous. It turns out, because we
have this discount factor delta, these
games are always going to be continuous
and they're going to satisfy the
technical condition, and therefore we
can apply the one-shot deviation
principle.
Okay, so let's uh
let's try to go through this.
So, I said, when we're analyzing subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium, the first step
is always identifying the subgames,
which is the histories in this case. I
think the second step I maybe I'll make
this observation, the key step
is grouping the histories correctly.
Because there's infinitely many
histories, and we have to argue at every
history
no player has a one-shot deviation.
If we just went through every single
history, we'd have no hope. I mean, we'd
never finish, right? So, what we want to
do is we want to kind of split the
histories into groups and argue about
the entire group of histories, and then
argue about the other group of
histories.
So, what's the natural way you would
group the histories here? If you look at
the way the strategy is defined, I think
it's natural to put the histories in two
groups, right? What would those two
groups of histories be?
If you wanted to reason about one class
of histories all together and another
class of histories all together.
Well, uh yeah. Now, like if someone has
defected or something. Exactly. So,
let's break the histories in two, and
let's consider
uh
maybe start with the easy case
where someone has already defected. So,
maybe you can think of it as
case one.
So, we're we're proving something about
every history. We're going to split the
histories into groups. Maybe I'll say
group one instead of case one.
Group one. So, let's consider history H
that contains D.
So, we're at some period, we're at some
history
contain containing contains
containing D.
And we need to check that at this
history, I mean, really that we're
reasoning simultaneously about many,
many histories, but we're going to let's
just take one of them.
And let's argue that neither player has
a profitable one-shot deviation at this
history. That's what we have to show.
Uh everything here is symmetric.
So, I'm just going to reason about
player one, and all the reasoning I do
would also apply to player two.
So, let's focus on player one.
And maybe uh
a good way of saying this, sometimes we
say if I deviate So, let's look at a
one-shot deviation
versus if I follow the strategy.
Let's just understand what we're trying
to show before we add all the details.
We're considering a history
that contains
some D. So, someone has defected in the
past.
We're trying to check that player one
does not have a profitable one-shot
deviation from this strategy, from this
grim trigger strategy. So, we're going
to compare what happens if player one
follows the strategy, what happens from
here on out, versus what happens if
player one
chooses a one-shot deviation.
In general, there could be many one-shot
deviations because there could be many
different actions the player could
deviate to. But because this game only
has two actions, there's only one
one-shot deviation. If I don't do what
I'm supposed to today, there's only one
other thing I could do. So, instead of
having many different one-shot
deviations, namely the number of actions
minus one, we just have one of them.
And what I want to keep track of is what
happens from today onward
if I follow the strategy, and what
happens from today onward if I deviate.
So, let's start what happen with what
happens if I follow the strategy.
What's going to be the future
path of play from here on out?
Well, both of us are following the
strategy,
and the strategy says if a history
contains D, we better defect.
So, that means today
we're both going to defect. That's what
happens if we follow the strategy.
Again, defecting is an action, it's not
the same as deviating from a strategy
profile. So, um
I'm just talking about the action
defect. Then what happens the next day?
Yeah. Continue to defect. Continue to
defect because if you've already
defected here, and then we both defect
here, we'll certainly
from this perspective, we look back, we
see someone's defected, so we're just
going to have DD forever.
What if player one chooses a one-shot
deviation? Now, what is the future going
to look like? Let's start here. What's
going to happen in this period if player
one
deviates? Well, player one is supposed
to play D,
so a deviation means they play C.
So, we're going to get CD today.
And then
from here on out, it's just a one-shot
deviation, so everyone's going to follow
the strategy.
If we'd already defected at this point,
certainly, you know, we still defected
here, so we're just going to have DD DD
DD.
So, is this one-shot deviation
profitable or not?
No, because
it's actually easy to see.
Here I do worse today,
and then I do just as well from here on
out. So, certainly this is actually
strictly worse, so this is actually
strictly unprofitable.
So, this one-shot deviation makes me
strictly worse off than if I follow the
equilibrium strategy profile.
Okay, now let's look at group two.
Now, I only reasoned about a single
history and a single player, but the
reasoning is symmetric for player two,
and this reasoning applies to any
history in the first group. So, I kind
of simultaneously dealt with many, many
histories that look the same.
Now, let's look at group two. This is
the harder case.
So, group two is going to be all
histories
that don't contain D.
So, let's consider
a history H
that does not contain D.
It's a minor point, but why don't I say
consider history H that just consists of
C?
That would You might think another way
of saying it. Well, I'm making sure that
I cover the null history, right? So, one
history is the game has started, nothing
has happened so far. I want to make sure
that counts. That history does not
contain D, but it also isn't just C, so
I I have to say it this way.
Okay, and now let's go through the same
reasoning. We have player one,
and they can either
follow the strategy
or
OST, one-shot deviate.
And let's see what happens.
So, following the strategy is pretty
clear. What's going to happen from here
on out if we
no one has deviated so far,
and we follow the grim trigger strategy,
what does the future look like? What's
the path of play? Yeah. Cooperation
every round. Cooperation every round,
right?
Because that's what we're we're doing.
If no one's deviated, we cooperate.
We cooperate again, no one's deviated,
we cooperate again, and so on. Okay?
What about the one-shot deviation?
Uh yeah, over here. Um
you I would defect in the first round.
>> Okay, so let's let's break it up. Let's
do the first round. Yeah, so I defect
here, okay? And then what is and what
and what's this going to be?
>> Cooperate. Cooperate, okay. So, uh
that's the one-shot deviation, great.
And then what happens after that? I
believe following the appropriate
strategy after that, we would be
defecting. Exactly right.
So,
this is
kind of the key point and can confuse
people a lot. I said this is a one-shot
deviation,
but what's happening is changing in
every subsequent period.
Can you reconcile that? Why I It's a
one-shot deviation, but if I look at
this, it doesn't look one-shot. So, you
are right, but but this is a a tricky
point. Can you explain what's what's
happening? Well, the So, if I like let's
say at time equals zero right now, I'm
going to make one decision Right. which
my
cooperate to defect. Exactly right.
Assuming this grim trigger strategy that
we have kind of set in stone before we
started this game,
based on that, the strategy dictates
that every future period must defect.
And so,
based on that, then
we we are going to defect in the
Exactly, great explanation. So,
um
here, why am I playing D Why are we
playing DD here rather than CC? It's not
because a player is changing what their
strategy does at this history, it's that
we've reached a different history than
before. So, the function the strategy
hasn't changed, but the history, what
we're plugging into the function, has
changed, exactly as you explained.
So, let's go over it one last time.
I one shot deviate today. I'm supposed
to play C
and I play D.
Subsequently, I follow my strategy, but
now if we're here and we look back, we
say wait a second, someone defected
yesterday.
The history contains D and therefore the
grim trigger strategy specifies that we
both play D.
And we continue following this from here
on out. Any questions? I think this is
sort of the crucial step. Any questions
on this?
Okay. So now let's compare these
payoffs. If we do CC every period, we
get 2 2 2 2.
Now, what happens? I get
So here we can see exactly what's kind
of the fundamental idea about
punishments.
If I deviate from cooperate to defect
today, I gain today.
We know I must gain today because CC is
not a Nash equilibrium of the stage
game. What it means for CC to not be a
Nash equilibrium of the stage game is
precisely that I can behave differently
today and increase my payoff today from
the stage game.
But I may not want to do that because if
I do this,
we're going to observe that tomorrow and
I'm going to experience a punishment
from here on out.
And in order for this not to be
profitable, it must be that the
punishment is sufficient to offset the
gain. Which is exactly going to be true
if we're patient enough and the future
looms large enough. So let's actually
compute this. Okay?
Um
We have to do a little bit of algebra
here.
Well,
if we discount starting today, we're
going to have discount this by delta,
this by delta squared, this by delta
cubed, and so on.
So we're going to get
uh 2 + delta 2 + delta squared 2 + delta
cubed 2
and so on.
Again, I'm using this trick
that I'm focusing just on the payoffs
here, right? It could be that this that
the history we're at is period a billion
and everything is discounted by delta to
the billion, but I've just factored that
out to the front and that's not going to
change my my preference. So I'm just
going to remove that.
Um okay. Let's do a little
simplification here.
We see a two in every term, so let's
factor that out.
So this is 2 * 1 + delta + delta squared
+ so on.
And this is one series that I think for
this class it's good to know the formula
for this. This is a geometric series. It
converges because delta is less than one
and the formula for this is it's just 1
over 1 minus delta. Right?
So this is going to be 2 * 1 over 1
minus delta.
Let's just make sure this formula makes
sense.
If delta is really close to zero,
then this series is basically just one.
And that makes sense. 1 over 1 minus
basically zero is is one.
If delta gets very close to one,
this series gets really really big.
And indeed, as delta gets really close
to one, the thing in the bottom here
gets really close to zero and therefore
the reciprocal of it gets really really
big.
Is that intuitive?
Um okay. Now let's compare that
to what happens here.
Well, this is actually pretty easy to
calculate, right? What is the What is
this stream?
Well, it's uh you know, it's 3 +
delta * 0 + delta squared * 0 + dot dot
dot. Well, the zeros don't matter.
So we just get three.
So what is our equilibrium condition?
So what we see is that every history in
this group
our deviation is not profitable as long
as this is greater than equal to this.
Right? And remember equality is okay
because if we have equality, then that
means the deviation gives you exactly
the same payoff as on path. Nash
equilibrium allows that. So the
condition is
over 1 minus delta
must be
greater than or equal to
three.
Let's just do a little
algebra here. Let's move the 1 minus
delta to this side. We get 2 is greater
than or equal to 3
* 1 minus delta,
which is 3 minus 3 delta.
And now we move three delta over here,
two over here
and we get three delta greater than or
equal to one
or in other words, delta is greater than
or equal to 1/3.
It's very easy when you're doing this
algebra to to get the sign wrong.
And that's why keeping track
that we better get an inequality that
has this form, delta greater than
something, because we know that this
should be an equilibrium if and only if
delta is large enough. So if I made a
mistake and I got delta less than or
equal to three, I would know I'd made a
mistake if I if I understand the
economic intuition. So that's a good tip
for exams.
Okay. So we intuited
that this strategy would be a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium if the players
are patient enough, if delta is large
enough, and our calculation found the
exact threshold, which is exactly 1/3.
And that threshold reflects
the ratio between the one shot gain from
defecting
and the subsequent punishment that I
experience.
Okay. Any questions on on that?
All right. Let's do one more
strategy.
See what happens.
Yes, absolutely.
Uh we have to be really clear about what
a Remember, an SPNE is a strategy
profile. So to What we're saying is the
strategy profile where both players use
the grim trigger strategy is a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium if and only if
delta is large enough.
Now you're right that at histories where
someone has already defected,
there's never a profitable deviation.
No matter the value of delta. Right? If
we go to group one, this deviation was
never profitable.
But to be a Nash equilibrium, it's not
enough to say there's some histories
with where the no deviation is
profitable. SPNE is really strong. It
says at every history,
no deviation can be profitable.
So that's only going to hold if delta is
greater than or equal to three. So
another way of saying it is if delta is
large,
whatever history I'm at, no one has a
profitable deviation and therefore I
have a Nash equilibrium.
If delta is smaller than 1/3, there are
some histories where I have a profitable
deviation and other histories where I
don't have a profitable deviation. But
as long as there's some history where I
have a profitable deviation, that does
not constitute a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium and therefore the strategy
profile doesn't work as a subgame
perfect Nash.
Uh
the profitable deviation. I mean, I have
deviations here, they're just not
profitable, right? But the profitable
deviation will always be uh at group two
histories, yeah. So in fact, there's
Keep in mind though, this is when when
you call it group two, it's not just one
history. Uh it's actually many many
histories that all fall into this
Great.
Any other questions on this? Yeah.
Great. So
great question. So as always, we have to
distinguish between the strategy profile
and equilibrium and the outcome of the
equilibrium. I described the strategy
profile, but I should say what the
outcome is. Okay? So let's look at the
outcome. Well, the strategy profile
says, maybe it's gone now,
if no one's
defected so far, we cooperate, right? So
in the zeroth period, we should
cooperate.
Cuz no one it's the zeroth period. No
one's defected so far, so we cooperate.
Now let's go to period one, what do we
do?
We cooperate because no one's defected
so far. Period two, we cooperate. So the
outcome of this equilibrium is always
cooperate. Maybe I should have said
that. So
uh the outcome
I'm so focused on strategies versus
outcomes, I didn't even say what the
outcome is. The outcome is CC CC CC CC.
Right? So that's the outcome. We do
indeed sustain cooperation in
equilibrium, but I didn't say this
because I want to be clear, it is not
correct to say the equilibrium is
cooperate forever because that's an
outcome, not a strategy profile. But But
great question. Yes.
Yeah, yeah. So let's be clear.
Uh well, I guess it depends what you
mean. The outcome of the grim trigger
strategy profile is always is CC CC. But
that strategy profile is only a Nash
equilibrium if delta is greater than or
equal to 1/3. For any strategy profile,
I can compute what the outcome is,
whether or not it's an equilibrium. I
can say if this is how we If they If
these are our complete contingent plans,
this is what's going to happen. That
doesn't rely on equilibrium.
But then a separate question is, are
those plans actually consistent with
equilibrium? And that's where we need
delta greater than or equal to three.
Is that clear?
Yeah. Any other questions? Great. These
are great questions.
Okay.
So, now let's look at one more, I think,
very natural strategy profile and see uh
if this works.
So,
this is called tit-for-tat.
And people actually have these contests
where you play prisoner's dilemmas, and
this strategy actually tends to do quite
well. Um
tit-for-tat, I should know the etymology
exactly what tit and tat mean, but uh
the basic idea is I'm always going to do
what you did yesterday.
So, if yesterday you cooperated, then
I'll cooperate today.
If yesterday you defected, then I'll
defect today.
So, tit-for-tat means
each player
copies
the opponent's
action yesterday.
So, opp means opponent.
If you cooperated yesterday,
I cooperate today. If you defected
yesterday, I defect today.
And that seems like a pretty reasonable
strategy.
Uh let's be careful.
I need to say one more thing. I actually
haven't fully specified a strategy here.
What have I not specified, and this is
crucial?
Yeah. What you do in period zero? What I
do in period zero? In period zero,
nothing's happened so far, and that
makes a huge difference. And but so plus
cooperate in period zero.
So, when we say tit-for-tat, that's
usually what we what we mean. So, in
period zero, I cooperate.
And in any subsequent period, I copy
what everyone else did.
So, the first question we should ask,
going back to our discussion we had, is
if we use the tit-for-tat strategy, what
is the outcome going to be?
And remember, we can ask this question
whether or not tit-for-tat is a Nash
equilibrium.
We can just say what would happen if if
this is played. So, what is the outcome
of this going to be?
We're not saying it's a Nash equilibrium
or subgame perfect Nash. We're just
saying if these are the contingent plans
people use, what's going to happen?
Yeah. Because uh everyone cooperates in
period zero, so it's clearly everyone
cooperates in period one, and then this
will the outcome is that CC is played
every
Exactly.
So, you might say, "Great. This induces
CC. This seems reasonable. Maybe this is
another equilibrium that's going to
allow us to sustain cooperation." We
already computed uh
grim trigger. Let's see if this one
works.
Um
it turns out it's not going to work uh
even though it seems quite intuitive,
and let's let's understand why.
So, what we want to do
is we want to check
is maybe I'll say TFT, tit-for-tat,
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
Well, I need to check at every history
does anyone have a profitable one-shot
deviation?
And as usual,
there's a lot of histories. I can't
reason about all of them, so I need to
break up the histories into groups.
How would Last time we grouped them into
two groups depe- according to whether
someone had deviated or defected in the
past.
How would you group the histories under
this strategy? Any guesses how many
groups you might have and how you would
group them?
Yeah. Someone deviated yesterday versus
someone cooperated yesterday.
Uh great. So, that So, I agree we need
to look exactly at what happened
yesterday.
And whether someone deviated tomorrow is
important. It turns out we want to keep
track of all the four possibilities
yesterday, and maybe this is what you
meant, right? So, yesterday it could
have been we both deviated, or sorry,
defected. I I always mix these up. We
both defected, we both cooperated, or I
cooperated and you defected, or you
cooperated and I defected. So, exactly
right, but there's going to be four of
them, right? So, we're going to group
them into four groups
based on what happened yesterday. So,
maybe I'll say
group one is a history H
with
CC
yesterday.
And now we're going to have
CD,
DC,
DD.
Okay. Great.
Uh yes. Just out of curiosity, or
question, how is DD possible? Like, how
is a one-shot deviation to DD
Great. But remember,
the crucial thing about the one-shot
deviation principle is we have to
consider every history, even histories
that aren't possible. So, you're exactly
right. Not all of these histories are
possible uh given the strategy, and this
is a common thing, but the good news is
this makes your life easier. You don't
have to figure out at which histories
are possible and which are not. Don't
worry about it. Just you have to look at
every history. And in fact, uh yeah,
it's I think this is the most
counterintuitive thing about all this,
but that's a crucial thing. At every
history, even histories that aren't
reached. Why? Well, because of
non-credible threats.
It may be that the reason a history was
not reached was that we were doing
something ridiculous at that history,
and therefore we still have to figure
out how people are playing at that
history. Um that's that's the key point
here.
Um great. Again, I need to be a little
careful. I'm missing one thing. What
What's the gap here? I have one history
not covered.
The null history, right? There's no
yesterday. Uh
but since we cooperate in period zero,
let's group the null history with this
group.
Okay? So, history with CC yesterday, or
in this case
H equals
the empty set or with CC yesterday. So,
we'll we'll group this history into
here. Okay. So, now every history is in
one of the four groups. We've It's
mathematically it's called a partition.
We've split up the histories into
groups. And now we want to go through
our same reasoning here. Um
again, let's just look at player one.
Everything's symmetric, so we could look
at player two. We get the same answers.
So, let's look at player one.
And we want to compare
what happens if they follow versus a
one-shot deviation.
So, I'll maybe I'll say follow
or one-shot deviation. And then we'll go
through all these.
Okay?
So,
the history is CC.
I think for this it's easier to go step
by step.
So, let's
fill this in.
Uh yesterday we played CC.
So, today, if we follow the equilibrium
strategy, what happens?
CC, and it's going to continue that way,
right?
What if I do a one-shot deviation? I
would encourage you to to to answer this
in two steps. So, first let's say what
happens today. If I deviate today, well,
the outcome is DC, right? Because my
opponent was playing C today anyway. I
was supposed to play C, but I'm
deviating, so I'm playing D, right?
Now that we figure out what happens
today, let's figure out what happens
tomorrow.
It's a one-shot deviation. So, from
tomorrow onward, we're both following
the equilibrium strategy of tit-for-tat.
So, if DC was played today, what's going
to be played the next period? Yeah.
CD, right? Why?
Well, player one is copying what player
two did, and player two is copying what
player one did. Okay?
And then you can see we're going to keep
alternating DC, CD,
and so on.
Okay?
There's a lot of cases. We're running
out of time. Let's just do case two, and
uh we'll we'll make an observation.
So, follow
OSD.
Um
actually,
let's skip case two and go to case
three.
It's going to be more helpful.
Encourage you to do cases two and four
on your own, but this is going to be a
more useful case. So, if we follow, what
happens?
Well,
yesterday
was DC.
So, today is going to be CD, right?
Player one copies what player two did,
and player two copies what player one
did. And then we're going to see the
same pattern, right?
Uh maybe I should have done yesterday.
Okay. Anyway, this is
Okay. And if I
have a one-shot deviation as
player one,
I did this wrong.
We get
My original ordering was right. Sorry.
Let's go Let's go here.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. Let's look at the case uh CD.
Sorry, this is the more important one.
Uh if CD was played yesterday and I
follow, we're going to get
CD, DC, CD, and so on.
Ah, yes. Thank you.
Thank you.
And
exactly. Ah, yeah. I'm confusing myself
here. And what if we
one shot deviate Oh, yes, there's
actually anyway. Okay. What if I one
shot deviate today?
I'm supposed to play DC.
I'm player one, I defect or I deviate to
CC.
And then we're going to continue like
this.
I see. So, let me actually
Let me erase this one cuz it's just
causing confusion and it isn't actually
the important one.
I
I switch things. Okay.
Let's go over this slowly.
We played CD yesterday.
We're supposed to play DC today. And if
we continue, we're going to get this.
If we were supposed to play DC today,
but I deviate, then instead of playing
D, I play C. I'm player one. But if we
both cooperate today, then from here on
out, we get cooperate.
Okay.
Now, we need to check that neither of
these is profitable.
But I argue that if we look really
carefully, we can see that this is not
going to work in general. What's What's
the issue?
Yeah.
Sorry.
Uh but DC is actually better than CC, so
it's not obvious.
Yeah.
If we say one of these patterns, say D C
C D so on is more profitable than C C D
overall, so the
one shot deviation for case one is
profitable, then by default, the one
shot deviation for case two cannot be
um an improvement because it's the exact
Exactly. So, the key observation is what
we get if we follow here is what we get
if we deviate here.
And what we get if we deviate here
uh is what we get if we follow here.
So, if the stream D C C D D C is higher,
is better,
then we have a profitable deviation in
this case.
If the stream C C C C is higher, then we
have a profitable deviation in this
case. So, in fact, the only way neither
can be profitable is if these two
streams are exactly the same.
And I won't do this, but you can
actually check that this holds if and
only if delta is exactly 1/3. So, it's
kind of a degenerate case. For most
deltas, this is not going to be uh
equilibrium, and I think for this reason
we would mostly say we don't think
tit-for-tat is a very compelling
prediction because you have a really
knife-edge case. If delta is slightly
higher or slightly lower, it's not going
to work.
You can go through this case as well and
check that indeed if delta is a third,
this will be a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium, but for any other value of
delta, which is basically always the
case we're in, this will not be uh a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
Let me stop there. Great.